let's see who else wants to chat let's
go to the eight-six Oh area code caller
from eight-six Oh who's this where are
you calling from
hi this is Mike from Boston oh my god I
think this is the I think this is the
perfect phone call to follow up with
your previous caller oh good because I
I'm Ann I am in Boston today and I gotta
tell you the mood is down here I know
you are too yep because I think that
what happened last night was very
disappointing I think yeah I understand
we got the house back you know I
understand you know we finally put a
check on trumpet but you know I went to
bed last night and I couldn't really
sleep because I could just keep thinking
that you know it reminds me of the movie
Saving Private Ryan where where they're
on the beach and Tom Hanks is talking to
a sergeant or whatever and he's saying
like this is all this is all that's made
it he's saying that this is not an
absolute this is not enough and I just
don't think I don't know what the
Democratic strategy is but they're they
are not reaching people that they need
to reach I agree with you I agree with
you but you know I think it's also
important to you know things are not
really black black and white I mean okay
so let's take the house first
so in the house yes what would would we
have liked to see more of a margin for
Democrats we would but when you account
for gerrymandering and voter suppression
and the power of incumbency how much
better could it have gone in the house
under those circumstances it could have
gone better but the Delphi was not as
big as maybe some people would imagine
all right let me ask you this Barack
Obama I regard is probably one of the
the greatest presidents of my lifetime
okay and you know I'm in my mid-thirties
now and he got annihilated in his first
midterm election yep Trump is an
absolute clown has absolutely no
business being where he's at and I mean
and we basically just barely took that
pass yeah I mean you know it's just I
think look I'm good I think the
Democrats are they don't really have a
strategy of winning strata
that could go into a place like Florida
I agree I went to a place like like Ohio
agree go into a place their strategy
basically resonates with people like in
the liberal northeast and on the west
coast let's be there first let's
nominate diverse candidates let's
include everybody just for the sake of
being diverse including everybody I
think
and I think the missed I think there
needs to be okay that that's good to
have I agree with all those things but
for some reason and I think I think
they're really downplaying how important
and how and how phenomenally successful
the Republican Party has been with the
immigration issue I think that that was
big time in Texas that maybe I think
that maybe listen Mike here's what I
think is most important I basically
agree with you I mean there's a massive
messaging problem for Democrats taking
the house by the margin that the
Democrats took the house is really not
the greatest thing the Senate was simply
stacked against Democrats based on
horrible reelection I get all that for
me my concern now is okay we've got the
house what do we do to avoid getting
crushed in 2020 and having Trump
reelected because that's a real problem
that's a real problem and it's a problem
now and it sounds like you're aligned
with me in that if Democrats don't get
it together and figure out what the
strategy is they're going to get crushed
they're gonna get cut I mean look again
I voted for all about can you do you
think Elizabeth with with Rick dissent
with what it's named Ron de santis Ron
de santis winning in Florida do you
think an Elizabeth Warren is going in
there when in that state you know I
don't I really don't and I know that I
know that it can happen but I don't I
just don't know that particularly
against against the way Trump runs I I
am extraordinarily worried about that
Mike I mean I tossed and turned all
night I was up to 1:00 in the morning
look and look I was I was I was actually
your bado caller from a couple months
ago so you know look I'm I was dejected
that he lost you know he did get a lot
closer and I thought everything I think
everybody thought he could
but you know to lose it to get
shellacked in the senate like that I
mean Claire McCaskill and Joe Donnelly
were not even competitive no they were
mean they weren't that's that's that's
that's really my concern Mike because
this the Senate was stacked against
Democrats but that doesn't mean that
they've got that Heidi Heitkamp Claire
McCaskill and Joe Donnelly have to get
crushed right and they got they got
absolutely annihilated yeah and another
thing I want to bring out to well I
don't know what is with the polling but
you know you almost can't help yourself
from watching a poll because you want to
see you know the way things are going
but it always seems to be stacked
against the Democrats no that's like
that Mike I don't want to get too much
into that because I've got 30 people
holding but I think the polling
generally is right it's just as I
mentioned when you have so much within
the margin of error the polling can be
right and it doesn't necessarily tell
you who's going to win I think that's
the issue but Mike appreciate the call
hope to hear from you again Mike from
Boston there